what Leonardo this is not where I
thought this would go away
kill kill Broly what summon your persona
shooting with a gun dreams is a pretty
impressive tool where you can make your
dreams a reality by making any game you
want using your imagination but we don't
care about that Ben no no it got time
for it dude I want to see that I want to
see your your artsy fartsy whatever I
want to see illegal dreams I want to see
copyright infringement dreams these are
the best dreams creations that are
either remakes of videogames or inspired
by video games that we have found so far
and John Luke what do you think is one
of the most anticipated games coming up
that people can't wait to get their
hands on Animal Crossing that is true
but hear me out well throw one off to
our Final Fantasy 7 remake fans who
can't wait because we've got this Final
Fantasy 7 dream make it's all here and
it's exactly what you think it is for
those of you who are bummed that the
game got delayed don't worry you can
play it out here everyone's here it's
cloud in parent and Tifa oh my god dude
this is uh wow this is impressive yeah
right holy [ __ ] they've got they've got
all of the the features in I haven't
played the remake at all but from what I
have seen trailer wise and gameplay wise
this is pretty close yeah dude he's
playing a cutscene when you do like your
yeah you get these cool Limit Breaks
going on a cloud going to town up in the
air brought it back down dumped on him
it's like if you if someone were to take
like you're saying like the the RPG
system that they've developed that is a
remake of the Final Fantasy 7 remake but
put their own thing on it right like
that's what's impressive about this is
like you were able to successfully
recreate Final Fantasy 7 roommate's
combat system injury and dreams that's
really cool then you know I think I
really like the most about dreams it
kind of reminds me of like a you're
getting like all these things that you
can just like pop in and check out
you're getting small samples it kind of
reminds me of those like old demo discs
they have yeah yeah
today uh uh you know like I have a lot
of nostalgia for those it's funny that
you bring that up so what do you want to
try first
um Wow we got crash we got sonic we got
the final fantasy bike bike time to
final fantasy vs. 15 do you want to
check it out whoa it's here
god I know what that's about let's go
it's here yes yes start the demo I need
to know what this is
wait man this is just Kingdom Hearts
it's okay it's okay I still make sense
nothing makes sense anymore his eyes are
kinda where am I
we got dialogue trees in the end that's
it how that was it that's this illegit
oh no there's a person behind him that
knocked this model is spicy but I
digress
this is incredibly anxious it really is
this and this was embedded inside of a
demo disc inside a video for a virtual
demo disc inside of a video game at the
hag ground
I really like the dreams walking
animation stuff like a lot so now what
are we gonna check out we got umm the
crash bandicoot 4 yeah yeah alright
let's go there we go we got spins we got
whomp of fruits got the tutorials over
on the side we know how to jump we know
how to double jump this is pretty much I
remember crash so it's rule again a side
cancel died midair it's it's a very good
animation Oh
title screen the croc that thirst it's
already we're already in for it this
looks really nice this is exactly how
the opening of croc looks this this is
kind of I just actually weirdly know how
we were just playing croc the other day
to my house
saying yeah so I'm actually very
familiar with how this opening looks I
really like how crock looks he looks
pretty good he's kind of got like a bit
of a like a floppy thing going on oh
okay it seems like they got they got a
lot of progress on this yeah and I like
how you can do like the yeah yeah you
get the the legs moving too fast so you
can go into a the spin - ball look at
that menu
look at that logos really really good
we're sort of got like a like a hub
world okay
tutorial over there we don't need that
go yeah that looks really good dude nice
these sonic games
Wow Eck - so you have to go over a cross
to get sacked there's actually a map to
follow up there - oh my god this is I'm
calling it I think we should push maybe
and move on but this is this seems but
what are your wait Sonic Adventure all
days jean-luc I mean we could we could
it's you this scene this is really
extensive I'm impressed
I I actually feel smoking my favorite
thing that I've played I'm I actually
wish I could text Sonic to get up now
and no one there's gonna be more of this
talk to the guy with the crowbar
oh you're Morgana ah the brains of the
operation hello cat want a pizza let's
play the music yeah
cheese pizza ah there's our Joker he
looks cool and extra style what you know
sometime hope the butterfly are oh my
god
what is happening Oh clucking excuse me
where you people that's dumb button what
whoa reaction this cease to exist as we
look good and cool such as well off it's
just damn it
[Music]
it's not a bad looking pizza yeah right
Oh
Sears are rolling back the ladder
salesman Oh Oh No do you don't want
anything right now
Miki's profit margins what and that's
what she catches okay at this point if
Miku doesn't show up on a be upset what
Leonardo this is not where I thought
this would go I kill him kill Broly what
summon your persona shoot him with a gun
I'm gonna pizza slice him
is that his all-out attack maybe I spoke
too soon maybe this is the thing that I
like the most nice eye button so good at
it
we need me to play any other persona
ones after this okay Ben yes
Metal Gear yes one of your favorites
it's got to happen you knew it had to
happen yes it's it's even got like the
weird filter on it yeah which I'm really
into wow this is impressive looking also
the camera angles move yeah there's
still my favorite thing besides walking
animations and dreams is just it's real
good this is it this is premium Metal
Gear content this is the highest quality
tactical espionage action that's gotta
get your head wrapped around it the
concepts and the ideas okay so this is
it's all there christos oh there we go
behind D huh
that's behind in this kind of weather
what so that's another game we're really
excited for John Luke uh well I'm pretty
excited for Resident Evil 3 is there any
Resident Evil related stuff you got for
me I've got you it even has oh my god an
old Wow Sony boot thing oh my heart are
you feeling it holy [ __ ] yeah this is I
was not expecting that as illegal as it
gets
whoa does he save the sound this is the
best possible
so sometimes you record things through
your microphone and upload them but yeah
so here we are we've got this it's got
tank controls X obviously and fixed
camera angles even when you open the
doors please tell me does the door thing
oh yeah yeah good so yeah you can even
get your resident evil' fix in here yeah
okay there we go
perfect take that key give me that key
perfect we're standing in the toilet
that's the content I'm here for one of
the things you wanted to see was like a
run back on that press conference yeah I
mean at the thing that we all remember
about cyberpunk was when Keanu Reeves
came out I think this is my favorite
thing that Dreamz has ever done so we've
got you're supposed to interrupt him in
between his speaking so that you keep
him on stage longer and this is this is
the future cheer for him yes you didn't
think so yeah that's nice I said you're
breathtaking keep pointed up the idea of
it like a crowd simulator yeah it's a
Keanu Reeves crowd soon but uh this is
really impressive though oh wow so you
actually have like your throttle and you
can move this is some rogue squadron
type here dude oh this one this is maybe
the most impressive from just like a how
did they even replicate this yeah it's
it's very on point look at that and it
has the dude like it looks so good
but this this is so crazy
yeah I've seen this one floating around
on like social media and stuff it is
it's crazy impressive welcome to critic
Ross ah look it's really well done yeah
right Wow
and you actually like you wow that's a
lot actually Isabel's here oh look at
him just want to fight him or make out I
mean you know whatever works oh you
actually have to put it in the thing
what wait hold on I'm not gonna actually
like okay I was gonna say that was a
pretty cool way to intro that this is
exactly how it boots up Oh nan Tondo
[Laughter]
Rolly
I like this gasps look roll
yeah it's like the file dude top-secret
bloodstone nightfire overdoing Goldeneye
yeah whoa from my inventory it actually
has the watch dude oh I didn't expect
this to be as good as it's turning out
to be this is really impressive that man
is no longer one hole nice okay cool
cool this is fantastic but this is kind
of really rad it's it's like a bikini
bottom that you can just drive around
right around in in dreams I don't know
if there's any objectives in here yet
but you could do a lot with this I mean
you can make like a like a racing game
you could you could kind of make an
open-world thing yeah
portal time whoo people are slowly
getting portal technology figured out in
this game too yeah we've seen a couple
tests and they're not quite it's not
quite there yet but I feel like people
are getting there
yeah the physics though on that box are
actually pretty good with this like
that's that's really yeah yeah dude yeah
I mean like when I heard like dreams was
the thing I was like all people are
gonna make PT I feel like it's just
become like the quintessential thing
people try and like recreate now this is
really impressive though so those were
the best levels that we found so far
that are like inspired by video games or
recreating other video games if you guys
have any that you know of that you think
are pretty impressive that we didn't
check out let us know in the comments
below and give this video a like if you
want us to do more dreams videos about
other games that are being recreating
dreams or just original content we think
dreams is really cool and if you guys
like it we want to keep doing more stuff
with it
yeah sure share us your illegal dreams
but don't tell the cops don't tell the
cops
uh-oh hi everybody good day don't change
keep it cool